-Performing "Hot Penny Day"
from their album "Stumpwork,"
give it up for Dry Cleaning.
[ Cheers and applause ]
[ Mid-tempo music plays ]
♪♪
[ Tempo increases ]
-♪ If I could live across
the road from a boot fair ♪
♪ Wouldn't that
be something? ♪
♪ If I'm thin as a bean pole ♪
♪ I can slip through the fence ♪
♪♪
♪ I'm not here
to provide blank ♪
♪ They can make
their own blank ♪
♪ Our relationship ♪
♪ Well, it's not
what you think it is ♪
♪♪
♪ Hot Penny Day ♪
♪ Hooked over man,
woolen woman ♪
♪ I don't want to empty
your bank account ♪
♪ And give you nightmares, but ♪
♪♪
♪ I guess I don't ever ask
for what I want ♪
♪ I see male violence
everywhere ♪
♪ Beautiful face softness ♪
♪ I think big soft bed club ♪
♪ Hazmat suit, yeah ♪
♪ Health first ♪
♪♪
♪ Are these exposed wires
all good near the steam? ♪
♪ Hooked over man,
woolen woman ♪
♪ I don't want to empty
your bank account ♪
♪ And give you nightmares ♪
♪ But we're in the middle ♪
♪ Of what they call
three financial eclipses ♪
♪ Is it still okay
to call you ♪
♪ My disco pickle ♪
♪♪
♪ To recognize a smile ♪
♪ Try thinking of a --
a chameleon or a Pac-Man ♪
♪ What's-her-name
over there says ♪
♪ Don't forget to bring back
the blue sheet ♪
♪♪
♪ Can't you see I'm trying? ♪
♪ I was having a good time ♪
♪ And I didn't go to bed ♪
♪♪
♪ It's Hot Penny Day ♪
♪ It's a spook out ♪
♪ I'm not here
to provide blank ♪
♪ They can make
their own blank ♪
♪ Can't you see I'm trying? ♪
♪♪
♪ Can't you see
my bloodshot eyes? ♪
♪ Horse-head tea,
bad taste bear ♪
♪ Every day ♪
♪ I've been to
the top of a mountain ♪
♪ There's fire there
every single day ♪
♪ Kick drum ♪
♪ Sometimes I feel
like I'm just a loner ♪
♪ And that's that
stiff undergarment ♪
[ cheers and applause ]
-Come on.